hamish et alors là parce que je repense
à la dernière fois les divines où vous
nous aviez parlé un petit peu de vous
c'est vrai que vous vous livrez beaucoup
dans cette situation à ce que vous nous
dites énormément de choses se remettent
beaucoup d'investigations on enverrait
tout mouillé la chemise pour se voir
couper vous vous aviez même si l'arrêt
de votre envie de vous faire blanchir
l'accusé avait évoqué là qu'on va être
dans cette zone et il ya une autre
chirurgie esthétique et chirurgie
esthétique j'en avais évoqué et on parle
d'une autre qui est en vogue en ce
moment et qui pourrait éventuellement je
ne sais pas vous intéresser à mon nom ça
s'appelle s'appelle malades bien non
c'est pas très cher entre 1500 euros et
3000 euros
la bia place tu sais la chirurgie de la
vulve c'est par ce biais la chirurgie
esthétique des organes génitaux féminins
est en plein boom
l'intervention se nomme la bio
plastiques ou encore nymphoplastie si la
plupart des candidates invoquent leur en
coupant dans un pantalon moulant pendant
les rapports sexuels ou sur une selle de
vélo pour les chirurgiens ce sont des
prétextes la quête de la vulve est
parfaite on la doit au porno mais aussi
à la mode de l'épilation intégrale mais
alors au royaume des vulves qui sait la
reine des chercheurs suisses se sont
penchés sur le sujet résultat la vulve
parfaite n'existe pas les petites lèvres
d'une femme mesurerait de 5 mm à 10 cm
les grandes de 12 mm à 18 cm impossible
de fixer des normes en france c'est
surprenant l'intervention est remboursé
par la sécurité sociale
à quand des bar à bulles de là tous les
coins de rue s'est renforcée c'est
remboursé s'il effectués dans un but
médical et non esthétique
donc je voulais dire cette l'apia
plastique en france coûte entre 1500 et
3000 euros
avec ce qu'on appelle un lip au feeling
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
c'est sa fonction phénomène vraiment de
un boom a notamment en grande bretagne
il y en a cent cinq ans il y en a eu 150
ch et des mineurs de moins de 15 ans en
grande-bretagne en 2016 par exemple j'ai
d'abord me tourner vers le médecin mois
j'ignorais qu'il y avait une chirurgie
esthétique de la vulve je pensais que
c'était uniquement interrogées qui
pouvait être réparatrice vous imagine
que vous connaissiez vous alors je vais
en tout l'été le nom je connaissais pas
ça maintenant je vais très sincère parce
que sur un critère esthétique alors
apprendre à les confidences de ludivine
l'aspect médical
sauf que c'est dramatique parce que là
c'est même peine je pense qu'on est
vraiment au delà de la chirurgie de
confort c'est vraiment une chirurgie que
je pense dramatique parce que finalement
on se rend compte que ses fans n'ont pas
de pathologie
c'est un organe finalement intime qui
concerne on pourrait dire ça de toutes
les chirurgies esthétiques c'est à dire
le nez ce n'est pas une si on se réfère
le nail exposé au public votre vagin je
suis désolé il n'est pas exposé au
public
il n'y a pas de porte pour toi par pour
les autres et tout savoir et dans celle
des roches sur les toits parce qu'un pas
vraiment de chirurgie oui pour la
chirurgie réparatrice
les femmes qui ont été mutilés celles
qui ont subi par exemple une excision
pas oui effectivement et c'est très
important que ça se passe
mais la refaire des lèvres aller sur un
être avoir un bloc opératoire être avant
une nazie général avec des ris n'est
jamais la nation c'est pas anodin et
maintenant j'apprends plus que c'est
remboursé par la sécurité sociale mais
ce n'est remboursé que si aussi le
médecin déclare que c'est dans un but
médical le but médical c'est le trouble
psychologique
bah oui mais vous la gêne alors
peut-être que certaines femmes alors
peut-être je suis mes connaissances sur
ce sujet une véritable gêne ont un vrai
problème
eric qui fait que bah ça gêne quand
elles sont assises ou en vélo mais ces
deux êtres quoi 1% des chirurgies tout
le reste c'est à mon avis il y à l'image
de la pornographie qu'on a mis en place
et que les gens ont regardé en disant
voilà le membre d'un homme doit être
comme ça allait fin d'une fac d'une
femme de la même façon je pense que
c'est dramatique et quand vous direz
vous c'est une vraie dérive une vraie
dérive alors que caroline visiblement
elle n'est pas d'accord mais je suis pas
tellement je suis pas du tout d'accord
la méconnaissance du corps de la femme
la méconnaissance de ce que peut être un
complexe chez quelqu'un mais si toi tu
avais le visiteur du même si personne ne
voyait te dirai peut-être si j'ai si je
peux avoir une fille cachée derrière on
dîne et que personne passe à demander
toute la journée si si tout va bien de
ce côté
poser la question c'est vrai qu'on le
regarde différemment on se demande mais
non mais mais vous voulez il ne pas vous
y étiez importe que ce soit le nez les
oreilles le menton où la vue nous la
vulve pour vous il s'agit d'eau de faire
du bien à la femme peu importe à la
femme mais en l'occurrence partie cachée
même site une partie intime c'est une
partie qui est extrêmement important
encore de la femme ça veut dire si ça ne
lui plaît pas si elle trouve qu'il ya un
une juste pas moi une 10/20 quelque
chose de trop grosses autres quelles
politiques sont des critères
relativement objectif n'était pas non
plus c'est pas on sait pas aimer
effectivement une opération comme l'a
complètement anodine
donc les filles qui passent par là c'est
parce qu'elle constate que ça leur pro
ça leur pose un problème soit physique
soit psychologique à village elle vous
estimez que le riz comme jimmy par
exemple qui dit bon en gros la vraie
gêne
celle qui peut vous handicapez lorsque
vous faites du vélo lorsque vous voilà
parce que véritablement il ya un souci
anatomiques
elle représente aller 1 1 ou 2% devant
nous cette opération qu'elle représente
l'année ainsi ces nanas qui a ôté aurait
une très belle bulle si elle être
qu'elle est moche ça va non mais ça va
faire foirer toute sa vie intime on a
beau dire toute sa vie sexuelle et toute
sa vie amoureuse
ludivine roissy non mais je suis pas
totalement d'accord avec toi carreau
dans la mesure où de surcroît il y en a
beaucoup qui ont fait cette intervention
et pour qui malheureusement ça a été un
désastre dans ce matin parce que déjà le
pur pour cicatriser
6 quand même une muqueuse c'est très
compliqué je vous en prie je suis même
plus qualifiés que le docteur bas côté
au-delà de ça après se retrouve avec des
choses dix fois plus moche que par le
passé alors il faut véritablement y
réfléchir moi c'est vraiment une
chirurgie sur laquelle je n'irai mais
jamais jamais je penserai à ça autant je
suis parfaite à ce niveau là valérie va
dire c'est que vous posez la question
avez-vous des noms mais si voilà bien su
parfaitement
et puis avec moi on est vraiment ravis
de l'apprendre et cinq émissions
ban un peu plus ça me fait plaisir